you were just in our neck of the woods
at the Ed Sullivan Theater building
right I was yeah what do you got what do
you do up there we're based out of that
building so I was like I want to see a
Tom cake we were right there yeah did
you say he Prince Harry
I'm not allowed to say really Tom so I
signed an NBA whatever I understand uh
maybe he was in the building but I don't
know if that's for sure he was Mr Hanks
didn't give an old Harry up though not
tonight not tonight but Mr Hanks let you
have done it again sir this is a grill
what I do what I do you are just shining
bright in this film you have such depth
and range and that's why Rita said you
were the perfect Auto well she better
say that you know I'm sitting next to
her almost you know at least 20 hours
out of every day and you're about to
celebrate your 35th Anniversary that's
coming up that's coming up in 23. that's
right tell me that's how you celebrating
because 30 y'all ring it in with quite
the bang that was something else you
know it's funny it seems like it was
last year but that's how fast things go
along but that was such a great party
that people who were not at that party
claimed to have been at that party oh
really it was I can give you my advice
after this you and Rita feel free to
send me an info all you got to do is
check your map but we saw oh my snail
mail you got to go out and actually see
what the post office it's all good it's
all good Tom and this young man here Mr
Truman Hanks and he is popping up in
this film starring along yeah
with regards to in response to the nepo
baby headlines that the film industry is
a family business
the shoe industry is a family business
the car industry is a family business
what did it mean to have Truman starring
alongside it well look you know my I
think my kids are all like Renaissance
artists you know they can pretty much do
they are good at whatever they choose to
be but the the question here is is can
you make it stick you've got to have a
passion you've got to have a drive and
yeah our you know the the household has
existed in the company town that is that
is Los Angeles but you also have to have
the talent uh there's a combination of
talent perseverance drive and no small
amount of luck now without a doubt we
had a director who says well why can't
your kid play you as a an early age that
wouldn't make sense because we do
resemble each other a lot but the final
analysis is a decision that only the
person has to show up on the day and hit
the marks and tell the truth only he can
make that uh decision it was totally up
to him
it's our Dream project you would like to
have in which the entire family could
collaborate that's a good question no
because no because no because I don't
want it to be work I'd like to you know
I'd like to take a I'd like to take a
camping trip across the country
altogether right I don't think any of us
want to have to show up on a call time
and you know and ask the question how
many shots before lunch nobody wants a
family vacation Sounds great but so does
the 35th Anniversary sound that'll be
fun
[Music]